harry and megan's royal cover-up is
buckingham palace bearing its bullying
investigation welcome to entertainment
tonight yeah duchess megan came under
fire during last year's official inquiry
which was never released but now could
the results be hidden from the public
forever
[Music]
the queen doesn't want any more drama
she just doesn't want to have any more
dirty linen air in public
did you make kate cry no the reverse
happened
these allegations of bullying were
incredibly inflammatory at the time
the initial 2018 bullying report was
startling it claimed that megan quote
drove two personal assistants out of the
household and was undermining the
confidence of a third staff member megan
denied the allegations calling the story
a calculated smear campaign the palace
launched an investigation the findings
those are apparently top secret to quote
protect the privacy of those who took
part and to limit tensions between the
sussexes and the palace so how is megan
handling this new twist in the royal
rift well just ahead of the news the
duchess of sussex was supporting harry
at his polo match in santa barbara megan
looked chic on the sidelines in denim on
denim cheering harry on but you could
see the agony of defeat on harry's face
after his team lost in the semifinals
harry's dad prince charles meanwhile
posted this sweet throwback of harry and
will for father's day william who turns
40 tomorrow released an adorable new pic
with his children george charlotte and
louie royal expert katie nichols says
will is ready for his place in history i
think as he turned 40 william has never
been more confident more happy this will
absolutely be the decade we're going to
see them lay down the foundations of the
future
[Music]